تحب هوليوود المزج بين العمل
والمتعة
، ولطالما تم جذب النجوم إلى
ملعب الجولف
بالنسبة للممثلين ، فهي ليست مجرد وسيلة للاسترخاء
ولكن للتغلب على العظماء
في اللعبة ، تظل
عضوية أفضل النوادي الريفية
أمرًا لا غنى عنه
في
[الموسيقى]
لقد كان للجولف في تاريخ الفيلم
ماض متقلب إلى حد ما
على عكس الرياضات الأكثر شيوعًا على
الشاشة الفضية ، ربما
يكون هناك نقص معين في التقارب بين بعض
رواد السينما
الذين لا يلعبون الجولف ، هل يمكنني الحصول على فشار صغير من
فضلك وقليلًا  من الزبدة
مع ذلك ، كان هناك عدد من
أفلام الجولف الرائعة على مر السنين ،
لذا بأسلوب سينمائي حقيقي ، نعد تنازليًا
ما
نعتبره أفضل ثلاثة أفلام عن الرياضة
وفقًا لأرقام شباك التذاكر الأمريكية في
المرتبة الثالثة ،
Happy gilmore بطولة آدم ساندلر
القصة  من لاعب هوكي فاشل
يكتشف موهبة اللعبة
في المرتبة الثانية كاديشاك بطولة تشيفي تشيف وبيل
موراي ،
إنها حكاية العلبة من الخرق إلى الثروات تدور أحداثها
في شركة النخبة  untry club
وفي المركز الأول كأس القصدير الذي يضم
كيفن كوستنر ورينيه روسو ،
يخبرنا كيف أن Roy Tin Cup mcavoy كاد أن
يفوز بفتح الولايات المتحدة ،
فقد تكون هذه الأفلام الثلاثة
ناجحة ولكن بالمقارنة مع بعض
الأفلام الرياضية العظيمة
التي سقط الكثير منها دون المستوى المطلوب.
وسيط شعبوي للغاية ، لذا فكلما
كانت الرياضة أكثر شعبية ، كلما كانت الرياضة أكثر إثارة بشكل طبيعي
، كلما كانت
لعبة الجولف أفضل ، فهي لا تتضمن
تصادمًا واضحًا بين شخصيتين
يتناوب الناس عليهما ، لذا لا توجد لكمات ،
فلا يوجد اصطدام في الملعب أو على
أرض الملعب
.  أه أباريق
يبارزون إبريقًا يحدق في الضرب والعكس صحيح ،
لا تحدث هذه الأشياء بشكل طبيعي في
لعبة الجولف ، لذا فإن الدراما ليست
موجودة بشكل طبيعي كما هو الحال في الرياضات الأخرى.
لكي تبدو وكأنها محترفين ، يجب في
كثير من الأحيان إطلاق النار على الحركات عدة
مرات من عدد من الزوايا لجعل
كل شيء يمكن تصديقه ،
رمي الكرة بالمال
والكرة الإجبارية.  قطعًا
كاملة وغالبًا ما لا يكون الأمر كذلك ،
تعرف على من يمكنه اللعب ومن لا يمكنه اللعب ، لذا
فقد نظرت في بعض الأفلام في الماضي إلى
الممثلين الذين
يتأرجحون في نادٍ وأنت على ما يرام
أنهم لا يستطيعون اللعب لذا
تفقد الاهتمام فورًا ، فقد تنجح مع أشخاص آخرين ،
لكنني
أعتقد في البداية أن الأفلام
حصلت على المصداقية وتعرفت على
الأصالة من خلال عالم الجولف ،
أي فيلم على اللعبة سيكون
الضربة التالية في عاصمة الترفيه في
العالم
سيخبر الوقت